only a stylish marriage I can't afford a carriage
but you look sweet upon the seat of a bicycle
built for Daisy the village beauty is having a
breakdown who's the stranger why it's Francis
X Bushman there must be something wrong with her
differential but leave it to Francis not to leave
a lady in distress he's looking for his Scout
knife he remembers he gave it to his sister's
baby to play with Daisy tells him it's a two mile
walk to her home he's trying to think of a way I
have it you take your bike and and I'll take my
bike and we'll walk home together water brain
this is Daisy's father farmer gray and Horace
the town bully who's in love with Daisy Daisy
says father I want you to meet fancies we've
been bicycle walking together hello Horace
Francis Horace Horace Francis Daisy tells her
father's the first time she ever enjoyed walking
home from a bicycle ride the old man invites them
all inside for a game of puss in the corner Aras
refuses the last time they played somebody hit
him a rap in the puss and he laid in the corner
for an hour Horace plans to get even I'll fix the
big dude says Horace I'll break his bicycle pump
when Daisy first sat down at the piano the
whole village laughed when she started to
play they cried no wonder Horace didn't want
to come in what a happy pair and was Francis
a fast worker nowadays it takes two quarts
of gin and a rolls-royce to do what Francis
did with his little philosophy all right
Horace walk on now i nonchalant oh hello
Daisy I just happen to be passing by Horace
Gross lyrical and says I love you daisy why
not take all of me Daisy thinks it over and
tells him she couldn't even use part of him
I know you love that slicker but he won't
get away with it I'll break his bicycle pump
aras travels in the best of circles no wonder
he's dizzy he tells the boys he's going to break
Francis's bicycle pump but they beg him not
to give the town a bad name all right Horace
I won't break his pump I'll slash his rear tire
Irish tells Daisy he's going to cut himself a
piece of throat Daisy worked herself up
into a lather cries I'll shave my lover
got him Francis darling he was
going to stick this in your rear
tire Paulus points to his wounded arm
and Francis agrees to fight one-handed
Frances promised to use one hand but said
nothing about his foot he orders Horace to
leave town it's the kids last bicycle ride
and so Francis his rear tire and bicycle
pump in tank tells Daisy that he will love
honor and old baby water screams Sylvan air